this was not inevitable that's the focus
of tonight's angle
now people inside the white house or
national security establishment are
obviously extremely concerned about how
ineptly the bide administration is
handling the current ukraine situation
those individuals leaked information to
the new york times which today
published the embarrassing details of
the biden team's feudal attempts to woo
china into helping us avert war in
ukraine the times noting that each time
the chinese officials rebuffed the
americans u.s officials got intel
showing beijing had shared information
with moscow telling the russians that
the united states was trying to sow
discord and that china would not try to
impede russian plans and actions
now
the very idea that the administration
thought that they could get the ccp to
act in our interest is delusional
well that's the thinking of someone who
knows literally nothing about the way
our biggest adversary operates
yet that's been the exact mindset of
biden's china point man for over a year
now
remarkably short time china has produced
unprecedented economic growth china's
partnership and leadership on this issue
of extraordinary international
consequence is essential it is
imperative that we the united states the
second biggest emitter and china
and the rest of the world
are all pulling together in the same
direction in this critical effort
climate change well john kerry has been
an embarrassment to the country since he
returned from vietnam to condemn his
fellow troops
and this is just one more insult
and this time with heavy consequences
for america
china was never going to work with us on
climate never going to work with us on
ukraine nothing that's not in its
self-interest
and perhaps biden's kind of now
realizing this obvious fact
which would explain his deer in the
headlights look when he was asked about
it
are you urging china to help isolate
russia
i'm not prepared to comment on that at
the moment
translation uh we already tried that and
it failed epically
in fact it's totally backfired china and
russia now seem closer than ever
now first china refused to call what
russia did
in ukraine an invasion and then
they blamed us for the carnage that
putin unleashed
and today president xi personally
offered his support for russia on a call
with putin according to the readout xi
also expressed the importance of
rejecting a cold war mentality adding
that he seriously
and uh respects the reasonable security
concerns of all countries
look
the fact is china doesn't care about
people being slaughtered in ukraine or
anywhere else
heck let's not forget
china funnels enough fentanyl into our
country every year to kill thousands
hundreds of thousands of our citizens
they're committing genocide against the
uyghurs they crush freedom in hong kong
and now they're funding putin's conquest
of ukraine by buying up their energy and
even their wheat now this invasion in
many ways was made in china
and the goal is to test the waters for
an attack on taiwan
and once xi thinks that he can invade
taiwan he will
but right now there are steps that we
could and should immediately take to
stop that from becoming an inevitability
and make xi just maybe realize that he's
underestimated the resolve and the
strength of america
and these actions could make him think
twice about further cooperation with
russia
we need to gradually begin what will be
at times a very painful process but to
decouple from china it's not going to
happen overnight
it's going to require astute political
leadership steely determination
and a little consumer sacrifice on our
part
this will include de-linking our
manufacturing on key technologies
raising tariffs were necessary to
preserve made in america and canceling
student visas about 340 000 chinese
students studying here right now
why are we training china's next
generation all of whom are approved to
be here by the ccp why are we training
them in stem fields
and at some point down the road we know
they're just going to turn around and
use what they've learned here against us
or our allies
in order for america to regain our
leverage with china and russia which we
desperately need
we have to drop the notion that either
we'll ever care about adhering to a
rules-based international order we keep
hearing them blathering about uh in
international think tanks thanks that's
just cooked up in think tanks
and later invoked by ignorant globalists
like john kerry
you have to understand the long arc of
chinese and russian history to
understand that both putin and xi
are both unfailingly ruthless
and supremely nationalistic
meanwhile they exploit weakness wherever
they see it
whether it's financial
or
cultural so russia and china respect
only strength
and this administration has shown them
only weakness from day one
now
once we were a driver of our own foreign
policy but now under biden
we take cues from other nations that
don't necessarily share our national
security priorities like germany
we were once proud as a nation to teach
our children about the brilliance and
sacrifice of our founders
but now in our schools
we teach them to hate our history and
revile our riches traditions
this all must end
rebuilding our economy requires becoming
independent of despotic regimes
loving our country and it means
returning to the energy independence of
the trump era
it's time for biden to exile john kerry
to massachusetts or wherever the heck he
can kite surf or whatever he does all
year round
and as we just heard from peter ducey
congress is going to be getting a
request
for 6.4 billion dollars in emergency
funding for ukraine we're either going
to have to print that money or borrow it
we don't have it
questions about how exactly this money
will be used to push back the russians
or
i guess humanitarian help alleviating
ukrainian suffering those questions must
be raised now and answered
in other words will spending this money
be akin to painting a house
with a huge hole in the roof
in other words a waste
the situation in ukraine is
heartbreaking and it's infuriating
but it was one that was not inevitable
biden's weak presidency controlled by
the climate change crowd helped create
the tragedy unfolding in ukraine tonight
and as long as china is aligned with
russia and as long as china gives them
financial cushion to blunt sanctions
putin's just going to have his way
and no amount of american dollars spent
in ukraine will change that
and that's the angle hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else